what's up everybody it's warren welcome
back to the cosmic wonder where we talk
all things marvel and mcu and i'm
actually about to head to the airport
for the eternals red carpet premiere in
la but of course you know i had to do a
spider-man video before i left because
we have some news about toby maguire
today and a few other bits and pieces of
spider-man news as well and speaking of
spider-man we are doing a giveaway this
is going to be a really really cool one
i don't know if you can see very well
there because of the glare but
really excited about this giveaway it's
a super awesome spider-man collectible
this was provided by sidekick central in
utah follow them on instagram their new
small business or if you're in utah go
check out their store because it is
awesome to enter all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel and my other
channel with chris cosmic culture we'll
be picking a winner from the comment
section in a couple of weeks so be sure
to comment on a lot of videos and of
course if you love the mcu be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos so of course we do
have some toby mcguire news today like i
mentioned before but we're also going to
be talking about that second trailer and
about that sixth villain of the sinister
six and we'll go ahead and start off
with that trailer because well i know
that's what everybody's wondering about
right now there has been talks that the
trailer could be coming out this week
and i just want to go ahead and state
that i do not think that this is the
case the last time i did an update video
on the trailer we talked about october
25th possibly being the date that the
trailer could come out and although of
course this is not confirmed it doesn't
look like anything has changed but it
actually looks like we have more
pointing towards this actually being the
date or sometime very close to it this
week today actually we have the eternals
premiere so i don't think marvel's going
to be wanting a spider-man trailer to
take away from that and not to mention
this week sony is actually releasing the
uncharted trailer which also stars tom
holland and although i do think it would
be pretty cool if tom holland got two
trailers released in one week i don't
think that's the strat i don't think
that this is going to be sony's plan so
i really don't think it's going to be
this week despite some rumors going
around now the other rumor coming from
some insiders is that the trailer will
come before the eternals is released to
the public and one could obviously see
the reasoning behind this once the
eternals hits the theaters and attracts
a lot of people to go to the theaters
and watch the movie they will see the
spider-man trailer before the film and
it's marvel so it'll be a marvel trailer
this puts the 25th at a pretty good date
that would be a week from today it would
also be a little bit more than a week
away from the eternal's release and it
would be about a month and a half away
from the release of spider-man no way
home which is kind of cutting it a
little close for a second trailer
however this is one of the most
anticipated movies of all time it's
getting up there with the vendors
in-game in fact some people have said
the hype has passed avengers in game but
the point is people are going to see
this movie no matter what and that's of
course due to the rumors and a lot of
evidence pointing towards toby maguire
and andrew garfield returning as
spider-man in the film you've heard it
from me before i have talked to people
who are insiders in the industry and
they have told me 100 toby and andrew
are in the film other really big media
outlets have reported this as well and
not to mention in these reports they
didn't just say that toby and andrew
were returning they said that toby and
andrew and people like doc ock the green
goblin electro and others were returning
as well and that part of their report
have already been proven true so why
wouldn't we think that the other two
were coming back but again until it is
confirmed and we see them on screen it's
not 100 however i think a lot of people
really know what's up but a big question
is what are toby and andrew going to be
like when they return what are their
characters going to be like well today
we have a report coming from my peeps
over at spiderman no way home updates
and leaks on twitter at spider
underscore leaks if you want to follow
them they're coming in with some news
that says toby will look the same in
hashtag spiderman no way home as he did
from spider-man 3 just with a little
change he will have a slight beard in
the film to distinguish his character as
the adult version of spider-man and i
have to say i really really like this
now it makes sense considering the fact
that toby maguire is older than andrew
garfield and a lot older than tom
holland well not a lot older but older
he's 20 years older than tom and about 8
years older than andrew so for him to be
the adult spider-man is obviously great
this also implies that a bit of time may
have passed since we last saw toby
maguire in spider-man 3. we're not
really sure when they're going to be
taking toby maguire and andrew garfield
from their timelines we do know when the
villains are going to be taken and this
is largely thanks to an interview that
alfred molina did where he pretty much
spoiled the entire thing which i do
actually believe was on purpose because
you know they published it in a magazine
he said that director john watts was
going to take his character from his
respective universe in spider-man 2 into
the mcu from that one moment where he
was sinking down into the water right
before he died and we can probably
assume that the same is true for the
other villains as well they are taken
right before they die obviously they
can't bring them after because it would
just be a corpse and that would be weird
but they're not going to take them from
any other place it's going to be right
before they died but it does seem to be
different for andrew and toby which
makes you wonder how everybody is
exactly going to be taken from their
universe and brought into the mcu is it
the spell that does it or could it be
something else like the events of loki
could have possibly affected it we're
unsure as of now but it's nice to know
that toby is going to basically be
looking the same way in the same suit
that he wore in spider-man 3 which i
actually really really like that they're
doing that because if he changes his
suit i'd like to see him change his suit
much like tom holland spider-man did in
far from home because if you're not
going to give us a reason as to why it
changed keep the suit the same so i like
that he's going to be the same but he's
going to be the older more mature
spider-man and hopefully he's going to
be kind of the leader of the other two
spider-man when they go into battle
hopefully he'll show them the ropes or
the webs so toby with a beard incoming
and also relating to the spider-man no
way home trailer spider-man no way home
updates and leaks also posted that the
second spider-man knowing home trailer
is coming before eternals that's why the
photos dropped referring to the official
photos that we got from entertainment
weekly last week the tweet continues to
say shots were decided long ago it's
been finished as of now we'll go into
dubbing soon and this is just more
evidence pointing towards a date around
or on the 25th of this month hopefully
now as far as that last villain of the
sinister six is confirmed you've heard
me mention rhino before at the moment
those were kind of just rumors however
as of now we have gotten a leaked photo
of rhino now as far as i'm concerned
this photo seems to be pretty legitimate
so i can't post it on the channel but
basically it shows rhino in that doctor
strange magical prison type area that
we've seen before unfortunately that
would mean that venom probably isn't
going to be in spiderman no way home
again i'll say that if anything he's
probably going to be in one of the
post-credits scenes but sadly it's
looking like he's not going to be the
sixth member of the sinister six but it
looks like that is indeed going to be
rhino which i have to say does make
sense they're taking three villains from
tobey maguire's spider-man universe and
then three villains from andrew
garfield's universe so as of right now
the sinister six as it stands that we
know of is going to be alfred molina's
doc ock from toby maguire spider-man 2
willem dafoe's green goblin from
spider-man 1 and a little bit in
spider-man 2. thomas hayden church's
sandman from toby maguire spider-man 3
and then we have paul giamani's rhino
jamie foxx's electro and riz eifens the
lizard all from the amazing spider-man
universe if this is the sinister six
it's going to be a pretty good time
watching them on screen and those are
the spider-man updates today i am going
to be vlogging the eternals premiere the
best that i can so if you want to follow
my personal instagram you can see a
little bit of it there and of course if
you want to stay up to date on spiderman
now at home be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell don't forget to
like the video and for live updates you
can always follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
you